hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
bruh Beck I'm foreign again today we
have tons of before to talk about about
the new event that just dropped coming
from August 16th to August 30th called
raining inferno and for honor so as
always like the beef you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being bells changes new events hero
leaks hero updates patch notes all that
good stuff and let's get started with
today's video so to have usual bits of
info I'm gonna have timestamps in the
description if you want to know just a
specific part of the video and I'm gonna
be streaming as soon as this is over
we're gonna be showing off the new event
so come by it's gonna be right here and
you too so come by you'll probably have
a lot of fun in that stream but either
way the new event is gonna be about the
volcano called raining inferno it comes
with a new mode called infernal Dominion
in the event playlist new mask tons of
fire and a Hadouken emote coming next
week which is awesome and tons more info
which we're going to get into right now
so the atmosphere of the game is
changing with the new menu music a new
face off-screen and a new scorched
minions the first event is also going to
be is when as many infernal dominion
matches as you can and the reward as
everyone is going to get a volcano
symbol then the next events are going to
be winning infernal dominion games as a
night hero then a Viking and then a
samurai and then also those symbols are
going to be those castles like a night
castle of Viking village and a samurai
temple and those are going to be on fire
as a symbol the limited time cosmetic
loot includes an ornament outfit and
effect which you can like I said loot
for only a limited time I'll have a
video out in the next couple days on how
to get that the fastest so don't you
worry about that
the first weekly content is going to be
the mask outfits at 15,000 for the first
week and then go up to 20,000 steel the
next week so get them this week or
you're gonna have to pay more which you
definitely don't want to do these max
these masks are going to be different
perfection personally I think all of
these masks is really cool and they're
crazy good and they actually breathe
fire which is really weird as well I
cannot wait to use these in game and
each mask according to the devs
represents eight different demons which
is also really cool as well
and then next week's weekly content is
going to be the new volcanic destruction
blast which is basically the Hadouken
move from Street Fighter and that's
going to be costing ten thousand steel
for one week and then disappear forever
so buy this now during that second week
or you're never going to get this again
now obviously there's going to be a
bundle for this from August 23rd to
September 3rd for 30,000 steal and you
can get all the loot from this event
from the
after that you pick so if I wanted to
get the gladiator bundle for 30,000
steel I'll get all the stuff in that
bundle and the price goes down the more
loot you have because the devs do not
want to make you pay double for stuff
that you already have so I recommend
playing the game a lot more and then
right before the event ends or
technically a September second cuz
that's the day before this bundle goes
then just buy the bundle for whatever
character since you can save a lot of
steel from that so the new game mode
showcase is going to be infernal
Dominion some interesting changes
include in this mode no healing and
objectives minions don't give points
when you kill them but they do heal you
if you do destroy them and a wall of
fire around objectives which will
activate if you can test and objective
with another person so people cannot run
and must fight during the battle they
can run through it but they will take
some hefty damage from it so it's
definitely not even worth running
there's also going to be a boost
somewhere throughout the map when
equipped and when that is equipped the
player can have fire damage on their
weapons 20% speed boost and immune to
the fire walls mean you can walk through
them without taking any damage and
aswell boosting an objective now you
looks for points instead of two which is
a really nice iteration so recap you
want to be capping the objectives and
then boosting them and then when low
unhealthy want to go into the middle
world the minions are and killing them
for more health because since you cannot
regen them at bases anymore then rinse
and repeat until the game is over
there's also going to be some new gear
coming with this raining infernal event
these will go away when the event is
over so get them before the event is
over I tried to get my best photo from
all these weapons but they go really
fast in the dev stream and they don't
really show the whole weapon these will
be available in scavenger crates and
endgame loot and like I said they was
will only be lootable throughout the
event but if you keep them forever so
don't worry about them deleting it but
you do have a limited time to get these
the first batch of weapons is our Musha
berserker centurion and conch gladiator
Highlander Kensei and Lovering are the
next batch no bushi Orochi peacekeeper
and Raider are the third shaman shinobi
shougo key in Belk
for the 4th and then they last two being
warden and warlord and then lastly if
you are the top 10 contributors on your
console or PC platform and within your
region you will get a map sent to you by
the devs which is really cool so
definitely check your you play email if
you're interested in that like I said
you have to be the biggest contributor
in the faction war so placing down as
many minions as possible throughout the
faction
and that is also different depending on
your region so there's going to be one
for EU PC and a PC as well as na Xbox EU
Xbox all that stuff so you do have a
tons of chances to win you just have to
play a lot more and then to end we have
our question of the video and that's
going to be from the information I
showed you in the video and from your
own experience if you happen to play it
already what is your favorite part about
the event I'd love to know in the
comments below love to know your
thoughts and with that guys that's going
to be the end of the video today
hopefully you guys did enjoy I am super
excited to play this new event like I
said happen after this video on the
stream we're gonna be playing this we're
gonna be showing it off cannot wait to
buy the new stuff for my new characters
oh yeah I like the V if you do address
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being balance changes hero updates patch
notes leaks all that good stuff and my
two most recent videos would be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out with that guys so baby girl
yesterday think of Arts in the video and
peace out
[Music]